[Music]
it's the world's largest population the
second largest economy mit has one of
the largest multi currency reserves the
second largest military budget the
number one trade power globally but it's
better known as the world's factory
these are just a few of the reasons that
China has become a superpower now if
you're a regular viewer of visual
politic you'll know that we've done
several videos on this country we've
discussed its foreign policy its debt
issues we've discussed how its companies
have grown all around the world as well
as its political system we've discussed
Macau Hong Kong and suffice to say we've
talked a lot about China
[Music]
and we have done so because we believe
that nowadays it is impossible as well
as pretty inconvenient to discuss
international politics without keeping
in mind this huge global player however
in all of those previous videos you
could say that we've skipped a really
important question and that question is
really how powerful is China today well
the good news is that's exactly the
question we're going to be answering in
this video and we're going to do it from
three different perspectives military
economic and political and look even
though many people today think of China
as the second most important global
power not everyone agrees with this not
at all in fact some experts believe that
when China's potential is carefully
examined well it's not actually all that
powerful but then again there are plenty
of other experts who stated that Chinese
power is growing at an incredibly fast
rate and that the 21st century is most
certainly going to be China's century
now before you get started we should
establish one thing first and that's
what exactly do we mean by power is it
to have a lot of economic resources and
what about a big army or maybe it's
actually to do with natural resources
well social scientists consider
political power to be found in leverage
and influence that is essentially saying
that power is the ability to shape and
condition the events and actions of
others so the question now becomes what
is China's power what do they have in
order to leverage and influence other
countries well as I said a moment ago in
this video we're going to examine the
three main areas that most often deliver
that power and that's weapons economics
and politics and well how about we kick
things off with war
but dragons strength it isn't exactly
easy to quantify the military strength
of a country it depends on several
different factors you have to consider
how well protected the country is if its
soldiers are well-trained or not how
modern its arsenal is as well as a whole
bunch of other factors however despite
these different factors we can still say
that the spending on defense is usually
the best way to measure the military
potential of a nation further when we
analyze the money a country spends on
its army we also get some other relevant
information like how important a strong
military is to the government so
[Music]
according to the official figures in
2016 China spent around a hundred and
forty six billion dollars on defense but
as you can probably imagine China's
government is not a shining example of
transparency and some other sources
indicated that the number could be
closer to 226 billion anyway whichever
number is correct we do know that China
has multiplied its defense spending by
five in the last decade and it is today
the second largest spending country in
the world when it comes to defense
spending trailing only behind the United
States of course
five times though it's a significant
increase in such a short period of time
however this hasn't been disrepair due
to the country's GDP indeed spending has
been closely related to the economic
growth of the country having been kept
within 2% of the overall GDP and that is
not the end of it if we look at the
public budget we can see how defense
expenses have dropped from 12% of the
public spending in 2001 to around a
little more than 6% in 2016 and can you
guess what that means well it means that
China has made less of an effort when it
comes to spending than the u.s. when you
consider GDP and public spending as
reference points so take a look at this
chart for instance
[Music]
we already know two things first that
Chinese military spending will keep
growing at the same level the economy
does which will gradually shrink that
difference with the u.s. seconds we know
that military spending is only a small
burden to the Chinese economy we could
say it is a sustainable amount and if
the government needed to reduce it the
government could manage to do so without
in any problems
however it's now important that we talk
about military capability because when
it comes to Chinese military power there
are certain limitations what the dragon
lacks China's potential to operate
military force outside of their borders
is actually pretty low unlike the United
States China does not have any military
bases abroad with the exception of
Djibouti as we will see later on it also
doesn't have that many allies either or
a logistic network of satellites for
large deployments it actually doesn't
have much at all and then he must
consider that they're also pretty
inexperienced I mean it's been 40 years
since the last time Chinese troops
engaged in combat
[Music]
but does that mean that China is some
sort of paper tiger well no absolutely
not new resources are allowing Beijing
to make important changes and
investments China's growing military
potential has changed the balance of
forces in Asia and the People's
Liberation Army is now capable of
conducting operations on a global scale
China is making changes they have
reduced their military by 300,000
soldiers since 2015 and too focused on
military upgrades and their ability to
operate abroad the Chinese army opened
its first foreign military base in July
of 2017 in the African country of
Djibouti then in 2012 China bought its
first aircraft carrier from Ukraine and
in 2017 they completed their first two
domestic carrier with more to follow
it's also investing in missiles and its
air force China has put into service its
new generation g20 stealth fighter yes
it is going to take decades at a minimum
for the Chinese army to come close to
the American army but there is certainly
no other country out there with as much
potential as China and we all better get
used to having to deal with China when
talking about global military strategy
the economic power
there is no way to sustain any political
or military power without economic
capacity but there's more to it than
that
economic power has its own great
potential to influence other governments
and large companies and this is what is
happening for instance with direct
foreign investments which is both
entering and leaving China as a clear
financial figure amount this is not
actually very high just yet but year
after year this figure has grown and
grown in a previous visual politic video
we looked at how in the last few years
Chinese companies have started to invest
money around the world in 2016 excluding
Hong Kong and Macau this amount was more
than 180 billion dollars thanks to this
China is gained influence especially in
developing countries that have seen
quite the opportunity in this Chinese
money
and it's the same sort of thing with
trades but here China is by far the
leading global power and we're not just
talking about Chinese exports here we're
talking about imports a lot to pay
attention here because Chinese economic
growth has created a more prosperous
middle class every day more than a
hundred and eighty thousand people the
poverty behind and become a part of the
middle class that has enough money to
well spent
and this diva is something that has
caused many multinationals to make China
the number one priority that is
certainly the case of BMW where one out
of every four cars sold by this company
is sold in China a country where sales
are now 50% larger than in the United
States but there's still more Asian
assembly lines occupying several
countries for example Vietnam may
produce one components while than other
is made in South Korea and later they
are all assembled in China the world's
great production center in the
asia-pacific region hundreds of
thousands of jobs depends on trade with
China okay but not everything looks so
good there are problems too especially
when it comes to technology design and
innovation because well truth be told
innovation and creativity don't usually
get on with dictatorships but still
things are changing and investment trade
and multinationals are all things that
generate a lot of influence in indeed
[Music]
a growing political power
finally there is political power it's
often said that China lacks leadership
and further that's unlike the US which
counts on solid allies all around the
world China is some sort of lone wolf
now this has been said for years but do
you keep in mind that this is all
beginning to change China has bet on
increasing their influence on global
politics and is doing that to defend
interests that are increasingly global
it is a clear strategy the Chinese are
using their large currency reserves to
expand their influence in the last
decade alone Beijing has loaned money to
several governments and has invested all
over the world from Fiji to Madagascar
and that is not the end of it they have
also set up ambitious plans to achieve
their goals as an example the Asian
infrastructure investment bank a
financial power controlled by China and
based in Beijing will reduce the
influence of institutions like the World
Bank the IMF or the Asian Development
Bank all of them controlled by
Washington to some extent and how about
some more examples well there's the New
Silk Road the one road one belt the
largest infrastructure project in the
world then there is the China Investment
Corporation a sovereign funds that
manages more than eight hundred billion
dollars and invests in companies all
around the world and yes we didn't make
a mistake there that is billion with a B
so now you might be wondering has China
actually had any political success with
this strategy well the answer is yes
they have and that is well demonstrated
in the country of Greece China is
developing enormous projects in this
country like the Piraeus port or the
Hellenic on they sort of Monaco in the
heart of Athens
[Applause]
and well what's the result of all this
well blast June 8th ins vetoed a
resolution that condemns the violation
of Rights in China and it's not for the
first time
anyway China is still facing real
challenges perhaps the biggest of these
is its aging population I mean just have
a look at this chart but despite this
the influence of China and international
politics will grow quite a lot in the
next few years and China is already a
new superpower and well that's our
opinion at visual politic and now we'd
love to know yours do you think China is
a superpower
or just a flash in the pan and do you
think China should be included in the
international community to a greater
extent well as always you can leave your
answer in the comments below or in the
survey and don't forget to hit that like
button if you enjoyed this video and
subscribe for new videos every Monday
and Thursday further do not forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
Media podcast they provided the vocals
in this video that were not mine and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]